- Basically, this little sucker
right here
just rearranges molecules
to create
anything you want
in the universe.
- Okay, let me get this
straight, all right?
[scoffs] Just--you know,
so I understand things here,
all right?
You mean to tell me
this thing can make anything?
Like, I don't know,
let's say I wanted a...
pffft...
brand-new Porsche or--
[screaming]
Holy [bleep]!
This is awesome!
You guys should give this thing
a better name than
Energy Trader.
I mean,
y-you should call it
the Magical Super Wonder
Dream Machine!
- [chuckling]
Well, Energy Trader's
a little more accurate,
'cause that's what you just did.
- Mm-hmm.
- Huh?
- You just traded five years
of your life
for this bad boy.
- What?
[dramatic sting]
I'm not even into cars!
- Oh, I think
you'll like this one.
I got you the sport package.
- Five years?
Okay, wow, well,
that's a great detail to know.
Okay, this is still amazing.
I just--I--I gotta be careful
and stick to the essentials.
[energetic music]
Yeah!
Oops.
[sustained]
Yeeeeee-aahhhhh!
♪ ♪
[engine revs]
Bye, guys.
Wish me luck tonight.
Oh, [bleep],
it's a stick!